hello good morning and welcome to Sky
News breakfast there have been scenes of
open hostility on the floor of the U.S
Congress during tents and times chaotic
voting to choose a house Speaker
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy won the
job not long ago after 15 grueling
rounds winning over Hardline Rebels
apparently with help from phone calls
from Donald Trump well our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone joins me now
from Washington so another extraordinary
night there in Washington Mark but this
time with the result
this time with the result it's taken an
unprecedented length of time you have to
go back over a century to find a a
period where it took so long for the U.S
House of Representatives to elect the
person that is the third most powerful
politician in the land it has been a
very very chaotic uh four days the
president a few days ago said it was a a
global embarrassment that it was taking
this long that there was so much
infighting within one party the
Republican party and that tension
continued up until the last few hours
extraordinary scenes and as you say yes
a phone call into the Chamber from a
former president
a series of extraordinary late night
moments to end an extraordinary week
this is the man who would be speaker
heading to confront the man who just
blocked him
Kevin McCarthy had thought this 14th
vote would be his
he thought he could count on the
Maverick controversial conservative Matt
Gates on the left gray suit we can't
hear what they're saying but it is angry
stuff
it's after 11 pm they've been voting for
four days unprecedented for over a
century a government paralyzed then look
at this from behind another Congressman
approaches orange Thai Mike Rogers with
a few words of his own for Mr Gates then
restrained by another
this is today's Republican party and on
January the sick that turns out the
anniversary of an Insurrection which was
fostered by some of these people
it went on a few yards away another
congresswoman conspiracy theorist
Marjorie Taylor green controversial even
within her own party she has a call it's
Donald Trump DT to her he is still
pulling the strings or doing his very
best to
bobert
his divisive politics enabled this
Fringe group of ultra conservatives now
disrupting on their own
it's been four days of Kevin McCarthy
capitulating to their Fringe demands
they get to call the shots because the
Republican majority is so tiny
it looked like it was all over for
McCarthy for the week at least but then
the man who had voted no moments earlier
had suddenly changed his mind
for what purpose does the gentleman from
Minnesota rise Madam clerk I Rise to say
wow
deals done Democratic compromise or
desperate infighting which will put
McCarthy as speaker in a straitjacket
unable to govern to lead this place
and so there was another vote and this
time he got it
of which the
ancorthy of the
Kevin McCarthy the 55th speaker of the
United States House of Representatives
[Applause]
that was easy huh
I never thought we'd get up here
he'd reached the third highest office in
the land but through the most
extraordinary and messy of weeks
at there at the end you can see is the
name badge above the door of his office
an office that was once held by Nancy
Pelosi the Democrat leader or Speaker of
the House who he has now taken over and
over from because of course the the
Republicans now have the majority
incidentally at that office is the one
that the insurrectionists two years ago
yesterday
um tried to get access to as they
shouted where's Nancy where's Nancy uh
during the the capital riots now Speaker
of the House Kevin McCarthy but what we
have seen over the course of the past
four days and what we saw viscerally
over the past few hours
um was a a different form of dysfunction
um within American politics you could
look at this and say this is democracy
in action or you can look at it and say
actually what it is is division within
one party one party that is deeply
divided the Republican Party divided
between a small group of Fringe
politicians who have been able to get
their way and now have their seats their
feet under the table of very very
powerful committees within Congress
um and indeed have have got many
concessions out of Kevin McCarthy as a
result
um there has been a statement from the
president from Joe Biden who has said he
will work with Kevin McCarthy of course
a man he doesn't agree with one bit but
a man he knows very well because they
are both Veterans of Capitol Hill he
will work with him where he can so says
the president I imagine over the course
of the next couple of years we will see
divisive politics continue and and the
effort for bipartisanship get that much
harder because of the concessions that
Kevin McCarthy has been forced to give
to the extreme right of his party
monster and thanks very much indeed
now his book doesn't officially go on
sale until Tuesday but the claims and
Revelations laid bare in Prince Harry's
Memoir already facing a backlash in
particular Harry's assertion that he
killed 25 people in Afghanistan which is
being criticized by British military
Chiefs ex-colleagues and the Taliban
Ivor Bennett reports
of all his tell-alls it is by far the
most explosive but it may yet prove most
damaging to the author himself the
claims these Pages contain already
provoking a backlash
it is the revelations about Prince
Harry's military career that are
attracting the sharpest criticism his
admission that he killed 25 Taliban
fighters breaking an unspoken code of
combat
you could kill a hundred thousand people
but you just wouldn't say anything about
it
Ben McBean served in Afghanistan at the
same time as Prince Harry and count him
as a friend but this time thinks he's
gone too far
he's a good guy and he's done so much
for the country and
at the minute it's all being
overshadowed by him revealing this and
revealing that
and it was just like just stop because
at the you know you think you're a good
guy here's him falling off the edge kind
of thing and he's getting close to that
his words have also somehow allowed the
Taliban to claim the moral High ground
with a senior figure denouncing the
prince's comments about not viewing
those he killed as people tweeting Mr
Harry the ones you killed were not chess
pieces they were humans they had
families who were waiting for their
return
the loss of his mother understandably
looms large in the book but even on that
topic he seems to be alienating would-be
allies
as the former spokesperson of Muhammad
al-fayed whose son Dodie died alongside
Diana Michael Cole supports Harry's wish
for a new inquiry into the crash but
says this is not the way to go about it
what is quite clear now is that he has
completely embraced Commerce the crown
is left behind his Royal status is just
a calling card and from now on he and
his wife are in the money business
for now the palace has stayed silent and
one imagines they'll remain so at the
heart of this book is really a very
tragic tale of loneliness of jealousy
and of unresolved trauma but all of that
is presented alongside the exposure of
family truths which at best seems
trivial but at worst seems spiteful and
so that's why Prince Harry might find
sympathy in short supply it was a
Revenge issue here really you know he's
actually in his words trying to put you
know the record straight unfortunately
you know there was no one to advise him
in my view to say look perhaps is this a
good idea is it a bad idea you know and
he's decided almost on his own back to
put this out and of course it's going to
cause it's causing already huge problems
ahead of publication
and so his attempts to build Bridges may
only serve to deepen the rift a memoir
that will be hard to forget and forgive
either Bennett Sky News
joins me now from Buckingham Palace and
Melania it seems like everyone has
something to say about the revelations
in Prince Harry's Memoir but still no
word from the palace
yes nothing at all never explain never
complain that old adage of the royal
family playing out in real life now and
it's perhaps true that they may not want
to add more oxygen to some of Prince
Harry's more incendiary claims by
speaking about it hoping that perhaps if
they stay silent which is their default
they will simply blow over but the
claims are so explosive Chief among them
perhaps the allegation that his brother
the heir to the throne physically
attacked him but not just that also a
claim that Camilla the queen concert
League stories about Prince Harry to the
Press so it's hard to see how they can
stay silent even though that is what
they have been doing for decades but
Prince Harry is not done he's got two
more broadcast interviews to go they
need to there will be broadcasting the
next few days one with ITV here in the
UK one with CBS News in the U.S and it's
hard to see what more he can say because
they think it's fair to say that the
book went further than anyone even
expected we learned so many intimate
details about the royal family it really
peeled away some of those layers of
Mystique that the institution is founded
on we even learned the words that Prince
Harry said to his late grandmother the
queen when she died as she lay in
Balmoral after her death when he went to
see her so some of the themes in the
book I think will Garner empathy for
Prince Harry the obvious trauma about
the loss of his mother but some do seem
a lot more petulant there's an anecdote
where he writes that the Princess of
Wales was reluctant to lend her lip
gloss to Megan his wife so it's hard to
sympathize with him on that and I think
the jury is still out as to how Prince
Harry comes across in this book it's not
great PR for the royal family but it's
turning out not to be amazing PR for him
either and there's still two broadcast
interviews to go
indeed yes plenty still to come Melina
thanks very much indeed
also this morning a police say a
six-year-old child has shot and wounded
a teacher during an altercation at a
school in the U.S state of Virginia the
teacher suffered life-threatening
injuries but is said to be improving
investigators say the pupil who had a
handgun is in custody
ministers have been urged to back plans
to introduce a paid leave for
miscarriage with an estimated one in
four pregnancies ending that way the
smp's Angela Crawley says the proposals
will allow parents time to grieve the
bill will would give three days of
statutory pay leave to those who
experience miscarriage before 24 weeks
of pregnancy
now people in Ukraine are celebrating
Orthodox at Christmas today despite the
ongoing conflict the Ukrainian president
rejected a russian-declared Christmas
ceasefire saying it's a trap our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
is in Kiev
well people are coming out to church
services across the country despite the
fact that it is extremely cold it's
minus nine here in the capital this
service is about to start very soon you
can see people coming but it is fair to
say that it is fairly muted and
understand for understandable reasons
there is a conflict going on people
although they are Defiance they remind
remain extremely defiant after what
nearly a year of War they are very
fearful of attacks remember the capital
city and other big cities around the
country have been attacked numerous
times with cruise missiles and uh
Iranian uh drones so people are very
skeptical even though this 36-hour uh
ceasefire has been introduced one of the
interesting things that's happening here
is this is the first service that's been
held at this Cathedral under the
auspices of the Ukrainian Orthodox
Church it used to be Russian Orthodox
here and that reflects I suppose one of
the profound implications that again
Vladimir Putin has misread about this
Invasion remember of course that the the
conflict itself was as far as he was
concerned Politics the continuation of
politics by another means by by arms to
try to bring this country back into
Russia's political orbits but the Schism
here within the church is a reflection
of how badly that has backfired Ukraine
if anything is further away from Russia
than it has ever been before and we saw
somebody
um uh revealing pictures overnight of
Vladimir Putin celebrating Orthodox
Christmas he looked isolated in a church
inside the Kremlin remember his country
is heavily sanctioned and he remains an
international uh Pariah as far as the
ceasefire is concerned uh there haven't
been any attacks on major cities we have
heard sirens since that ceasefire came
into a place yesterday
but there are reports along the line of
contact particularly around back moot
which is almost that The Crucible of the
fighting at the moment it remains
extremely intense with both sides
blaming each other for breaking that
ceasefire the ceasefire of course has
been rejected by the ukrainians they see
it as nothing more than propaganda by
the Russians and also a way to try and
use a pause in the fighting to replenish
their forces restock their ammunition
and break up that the tempo the momentum
and the initiative that Ukrainian forces
seem to have at the moment foreign
[Music]
ER in Kiev now ministers Health leaders
and clinical experts were meeting
Downing Street today in an attempt to
solve the short and long-term issues
facing the Health Service well let's go
back to Westminster hear a little bit
more about it our political
correspondent Rob Powell is there for us
and Rob there's been so much focus in
recent weeks on the troubles in the
Health Service so what are the Ambitions
of this meeting
so it's being billed Anna is an NHS
recovery Forum you'll get NHS leaders
but also people from the private sector
the private healthcare sector ministers
and health experts as well all coming
together in Downing Street for this
forum hosted by the prime minister to
essentially try and share best practice
I guess to look at method Strategies
employed in parts of the health service
across the country that can be maybe
used be used elsewhere to try and ease
some of the pressures and they're
looking at really every section of the
health service from emergency care right
down to GPS through to hospital care and
social care as well now this isn't the
first time we've had kind of groups
forums like this convened to try and
tackle some of the problems in the
Health Service there was a backlogs task
force that first met last month that was
promised by Rishi sunak in his
leadership campaign over the summer and
I think when you talk to health analysts
and health experts about these sorts of
ideas they they say yes okay sharing
best practice is a good idea but there
has been Healthcare big brains working
on these problems for a while and the
issues are are kind of naughtier and
more complex than can be solved in a
sort of day of sharing ideas like this
labor have made a similar criticism
saying that this is essentially a
talking shop and the government should
have been listening to NHS leaders from
an earlier stage in terms of some of the
ideas that the government say could be
discussed things like rolling out a
virtual wards where essentially people
are able to to stay at home be monitored
their health is monitored virtually and
they are treated and essentially
consulted by doctors online and
virtually rather than having to go into
hospital I think there is a political
necessity in holding events like this
though as well such as the pressure on
the NHS and the challenges
um being faced by the Health Service and
the impacts on patients which is neck
has to be seen to be doing as much as
possible to try and tackle it we got an
indication of some of those pressures
yesterday when data came out about
ambulances 40 percent of ambulance
drop-offs in England waiting over an
hour to hand over patients we hear
stories of patients having to wait on
trolleys for hours days sometimes to get
a bed in a ward one of the main issues
being this delayed discharge problem
where people can't be taken out of
hospitals into care because there isn't
space in the social care sector there
isn't capacity there meaning that
they're taking up beds and that
bottleneck runs right through to the
hospital all the way to the a e Ward to
the ambulance Handover point on top of
that there are clearly strikes to
contend with as well the BMA will start
balloting Virginia doctor strikes in
parts of the country in the coming days
more ambulance workers will walk out
next week with further strikes by nurses
and NHS staff later in the month as well
there'll be a fresh set of meetings
between ministers and unions including
Health unions but also other sectors on
Monday they'll all come into Westminster
to talk to their respective ministers I
think as far as the NHS dispute goes
though those talks will only be about
the pay settlement for the financial
year beginning in April unions want to
talk about the pay settlement now the
2022 pay settlement that isn't on the
table so it's hard to see even with the
movement from both sides where a deal
might lie warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the weekend will bring strong winds
with rain clearing eastwards to leave a
mixture of sunshine and showers it's a
mild wet and windy start for many but
parts of the West are more showery rain
over Britain will clear into Eastern
parts of England during the morning and
that'll leave a scattering of showers
elsewhere with hail and thunder possible
there will be some Sunny spells too
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now Sky News has been told there's an
unacceptable cloak of secrecy around the
decision to scrap the body that was to
manage the restoration of parliament the
work is floundered after soaring price
projections but maintenance just to keep
the building open is costing Millions
per week our political correspondent
Amanda acass reports
the old Palace of Westminster burned to
the ground in 1834 without urgent
restoration it's feared a similar
disaster could befall its Victorian
replacement too but now the organization
set up in 2018 to manage the huge
renovation project has been scrapped
after estimating the bill would reach 7
billion pounds at least
I could weep for the five years we've
lost now we have no sponsor body no
plans to carry out the work and still
argument about whether we should stay in
the building while the work is done or
not this is not about us as MPS it's
about the building that belongs to the
country without full-scale restoration
the current bill just to keep the
building safe is two and a half million
pounds a week they're Around the Clock
fire patrols and work to repair
crumbling masonry is constantly underway
here in Saint Stephens Hall which had to
be rebuilt after the catastrophic fire
of 1834 work has been going on over the
past year to painstakingly restore the
Victorian ceiling but the real
renovation challenge is under our feet
we were refused access to film in the
basement but archive shows a Labyrinth
of gas and dripping water pipes threaded
alongside miles of electric wiring and a
Victorian sewage pumping system the site
is also riddled with asbestos
in 2018 Parliament voted to move out for
the project and set up an independent
sponsor body of experts and politicians
to lead it last year they published
estimates predicting the work would cost
between 7 and 13 billion pounds and take
up to 28 years if MPS Lords and staff
stayed put the bill could reach 22
billion and last as long as 76 years
it's ridiculous we can't have some
vastly expensive gold-plated plan
especially when the economy is in
tatters you don't need to move everybody
out but the experts argue that not
moving out will be more expensive more
disruptive more dangerous the MPS don't
mind having to move out for a time but
nobody wants to move out for some hugely
long period that we might never get back
MPS and Lords have now abolished the
sponsor body and brought the project
in-house meanwhile debate continues
about where they'd even move out to with
Millions spent on plans for venues in
London but ministers also suggesting
York or Stoke-on-Trent we just need to
crack on and do it and instead we Circle
background all the time and change
decisions there's been something like
over 50 fire incidents in the recent
decade and those any one of them could
have resulted in a kind of Notre Dame
style absolute burning down of the
palace parliaments told us members have
agreed to prioritize safety critical
work and they're getting on with plans
for the complex restoration and
developing a wide set of options but as
their Georgian predecessors discovered
if they delay the costs could get much
higher Amanda raycast Sky News
Westminster
the parents of a pregnant woman murdered
in Northern Ireland are urging anyone
shielding their daughter's killer to
find it in their heart to contact police
Natalie McNally was found dead in her
home in Lurgan in County Arma just a few
days before Christmas our senior Ireland
correspondent David Blevins has this
report
this is Natalie McNally she was 32 years
old and pregnant with her first child
when stabbed to death in her home just
before Christmas
he said God hey we are going to
face these days without any all our
presents were hard for all wrapped up
they're all upstairs and you look at
them and heartbreaking
three weeks on her parents Noel and
Bernie say it's possible her killer
could have fled Northern Ireland and
they won't rest until he's apprehended
like this is an innocent girl our baby
life
and I'd have to thank God in our last
a few minutes was she pleading for her
life was she pleading for her baby's
life you don't that's all comes into
your head our last few what was our last
few minutes like you know we feel for
the weak girls and this and women in
this community living in their own life
they must be terrified you know that
there's a monster still out on the
streets you know and I I I feel for them
like to tell you the truth you know
police have released these CCTV pictures
of the suspect on the night of Natalie's
murder and believe they've recovered the
weapon used in the attack
do you think given the nature of her
death that there is someone out there
beyond the killer who knows I think yeah
that is bound to be somebody's bound to
know the Killer and if you killed
somebody that way you can't just like go
home and act normally and we could just
you know fend in their heart you know to
give up loyal day and just go straight
to the place you know you can't be loyal
to somebody that don't understand
to someone else and you wouldn't want
that
Northern Ireland has the joint highest
female homicide rate in Europe storm and
fell silent when first Minister
designate Michelle O'Neill hosted a
vigil for Natalie
oh just
[Music]
born
to very good
it's so much part of our Lives haven't
we and this is not like that's not
really just
on a Monday well it's just I can't
remember I can't think to your future I
can't say there'll be no joy in life not
ever because she's gone and
they've lost their daughter and all they
have left is the hope of Justice
David Blevins Sky News in craigavon
at least 29 people have been killed in
Mexico following violent clashes
prompted by the capture of the son of
the drug lord El Chapo a video Guzman's
arrest triggered gunfights lasting
several hours in the country's Northwest
the 32 year old was last captured in
2019 but was released to stop a wave of
violent retribution Dan Whitehead
reports
Landing under gunfire this was a
military operation that ended in
bloodshed
pre-dawn raid a video Guzman son of the
infamous Mexican drugs Boss El Chapo
was captured in the Northwest city of
culiacare
sparked widespread violence
Sinaloa cartel allegedly led by Guzman
responded roadblocks vehicle fires and
fierce fighting left ten soldiers and 19
suspected cartel members dead
[Music]
even civilian passengers at the city's
airport cowered after reportedly being
shot at
Los Angeles
High number of criminal cells grouped
together to rescue a video and they
attacked members of the Army on site
seven members of the army were killed
and nine were injured
the arrest following six months of
police surveillance turned the streets
of this city into a battlefield
first of all regarding the case of a
video there is a request of provisional
detention for purposes of extradition we
think that the extradition will happen
in between four and six weeks from now
from the United States which presented
the extradition request
it is not the first time Guzman has been
arrested in 2019 he was taken into
custody only to be released after
further violence erupted
one year ago authorities in the U.S put
a five million reward up for information
leading to his arrest
[Laughter]
his capture is a rare victory for
officials in Mexico against this
powerful cartel with convenient timing
U.S President Joe Biden arrives in the
country next week for a Leader's Summit
with drug trafficking into the U.S on
the agenda
this latest single arrest is unlikely to
stop that flow anytime soon
down Whitehead Sky News
well time now let's take another look at
the morning's papers here with me to
review them this morning are Mariana
hotter and Yasmin Alibi Brown so welcome
back to both of you and Marianne we're
going to kick off with the story that we
didn't have time to get on to last hour
so we've been viewers have been waiting
for an hour dying to hear more about it
so talk us through it's the front page
of the eye isn't it and the headline is
British national security fairs after
Chinese spyware an inverted commas found
in government car so so do we have much
detail here
so some of the details are indeed and as
you guess obscured on account of this
being an active element of
um British counter Espionage I guess and
and uh security around diplomats and
politicians but fundamentally what's
been revealed what's been revealed to uh
journalists at the eye is that
um whilst doing kind of a really
forensic deconstruction of cars that are
used by diplomats and politicians here
in the UK they found secret SIM cards
that are planted that have been planted
into the sealed components that are
installed into cars by manufacturers
um that have been produced in China so
these are Chinese SIM cards and
obviously modern cars are basically
computers on Wheels they're transferring
data back and forth all the time
and so there's a really big challenge
around how you create vehicles that
aren't
shedding information or perhaps being uh
you know a bled of information by
agencies and actors in the global scene
that you don't necessarily want to know
all the granular detail of where our
politicians are where our diplomats are
traveling and and the kind of big
question is well how do you protect
against that and the other question is
given that we know that China is doing
this given that we know that because
they're doing this through car
manufacturers in sealed parts that are
being put into mass production into
vehicles that are being then shipped
across the world and then they pick up
the data from the vehicles that they
identify as being used by Personnel of
Interest
do is it time now that we actually
officially explicitly designate China as
a systemic threat as a nation of
systemic threat to UK integrity and to
our democracy
interesting question and we'll leave
leave you on that shrug as as we pause
and move on and but a really interesting
story that and we're going to
um the Ft next aren't we Yes Man the
story that you've picked out is about
house prices and what direction they're
likely to go in in the months ahead
yes and and nobody should be surprised
that in the condition where you know
situation we're all in
um with the cost of living crisis with
with the economy uh the spasms that
we've been through but the the story is
that the rate of increase of house
prices is lower than it used to be so
apparently according to the ft
uh in December it's gone down the rate
has gone down from about 4.6 to 2
percent but maybe I'm just being naive
but I think
we've been on a kind of mad ride on
house prices they've been going up and
up and up and younger people in
particular
just can't afford to get on the on the
ladder and we've got so greedy about how
how the house prices will deliver these
increases so perhaps maybe I'm being
naive I think that's no bad thing if an
adjustment takes place
the flat I live in
I bought for 23 000 pounds it is
appalling how much it's worth now quite
appalling
um and so I I don't necessarily think I
feel pessimistic about this but of
course in The Wider economic world it is
seen as a problem
well yes you're right anyone wanted to
get on the housing letter might be
encouraged I guess there are some people
that will worry about negative equity uh
you know that their mortgage is their
mortgage payments are worth so much more
than the the cost of the property itself
but um certainly uh one to watch and and
see whether or not those predictions um
bear out let's move on shall we to the
next story Marianne that you wanted to
talk about and actually it's the one of
the little news and briefs at the bottom
of the front page of the Daily Telegraph
and it's talking about the energy
support scheme we know about the one
that is in place for households but the
one for businesses as well is being
looked at again post the spring isn't it
yeah that's right and I it to X to an
extent feeds into uh yasmin's kind of
questions around house prices because
we're really seeing a kind of some
seismic shifts in the way that our
economy will be functioning and now and
into the future and part of that is
costs to business and then the knock-on
impact for you know their ability to
keep going and maintain people's jobs so
Rishi sunak and the chancellor have sat
down apparently they've agreed the costs
in principle
um which means that from April the
details are going to be announced next
week but from April there's an
anticipation that the energy bill
supports so the the kind of the
subsidies that are being paid out to
businesses at the moment to help them
cover their energy costs are going to be
reduced by 85 so in the six months um up
until now 18 billion pounds has been
spent at supporting UK businesses with
their energy costs and and the hope is
or the the modeling the projections and
plans that
um sunac is is working on is that that
energy bill support cost to the
government will be capped at around 5
billion pounds from April
that is a pretty huge reduction in
support for businesses and we know that
small and medium-sized businesses as
well as larger businesses that have high
energy costs and con energy demands are
already feeling squeezed that people are
facing redundancies that you know all
the conversation around
um public sector pay and the strikes is
echoed in private sector pay as well
people who are working for private
employers
um may or may not be members of unions I
hope that they are but even so they're
also feeling real term squeezes on their
on their incomes and businesses as as
kind of entities are feeling the squeeze
in terms of their cash flow their profit
margins and whether they can continue
trading
um there is no Magic Money Tree they
can't just keep printing money but to
transfer the burden of costs onto
private companies and householders
isn't sustainable I mean we're coming
into this with 12 years of austerity and
so people's resilience to to cope with
these these shocks to cope with this
this pressure of of on their finances
yeah it's it's not sustainable there's
going to be huge negative outcome that
will color the way that our our company
can our country can grow for yeah a
decade of huge challenges you're
absolutely right and I think businesses
also wanted Clarity because it's very
hard for them to plan but there has been
some optimism to see that the wholesale
gas prices seem to be coming down and I
guess the feeling is that energy bills
tend to be lower over the summer months
just very briefly on that
yes you're right so perhaps we've seen
the worst of the peak of the energy
costs and as you say um in in the the
spring and summer period uh energy costs
because heating costs are lower
however to kind of
um to to kind of counter that the war in
Ukraine has is not going to be wrapped
up anytime soon Russia know very clearly
now perhaps how the international
markets will respond when they turn the
tap on or turn the tap off so they've
got more leverage and we have more um
insecurity and risk so on ongoing
precious there yes let's come on to you
um the story that you have picked out
next is it from the times and this uh is
about
um well it's private clinics on the High
Street uh to tackle cancer scan backlogs
so fill us in
well I mean you know a lot a huge number
of cancer patients actually going back
to the the lockdown years
Diagnostics uh di the diagnosis is being
delayed which delays treatment and so on
so the idea is and I think I'm right in
saying that labor doesn't look too
unkindly upon such solutions that to
bring in the private sector
um to speed up the Diagnostics is
um what this government wants to do my
only anxiety which you would expect from
somebody on the left is that there is a
there is increasing evidence that our
government is very keen on the private
sector getting a larger and larger slice
off of the National Health Service